welcome to this video playing Grand
Master Chamberlain this grandmother
Gabrielle off I think Gavriel off yes
now I started on the ICC he was an IM I
know that I played him quite a lot in
the early days um age three that's an
early age three can I go with B 5 I mean
okay is preventing that okay let's just
develop at least I know that he will not
go he will not Castle castle long here
in this position p 6 be success i think
ii five maybe try to preempt e5 e6 okay
so it's just putting out his pieces and
going for good healthy development which
is not bad not bad at all okay I wonder
if I can play c5 here takes Knight takes
maybe oh I didn't think about this one
and this movie at all so if i take on f3
takes on f6 bishop t1 it takes on g7 so
that's not good okay
again Bishop f3 takes on f6 just losing
material some have to go here which
looks kind of shaky but if five is also
hmm also attacked that's not so bad with
the five under fire I can also play
Queen c7 to attack the e5 pawn even once
more and I'm threatening just to take it
out I mean how is he covering this
Bishop f4 looks like total bogus and 95
is definitely not a great move ed 5
maybe if he has some some tactical
justification for 9065 but other than
that it's really rubbish also 95 Bishop
d5 intending to take on f3 and Jay
Gorney 5 comes to mind f somewhat
unstable position in the in the D file
but still he played this he 5 very
quickly and it seems that he didn't
really think about it in much much of
concrete terms he just thought okay this
is normal and I'll push the porn but
this is not that great actually let's
see okay so
yeah okay I will take him and totally
take everything off him an interesting
moment now can I do an intermediate move
sir no I have to check him yeah a big
point is Bishop Jake's f3 destroying a
structure so I'm going to do that and
now here's bishop moves like Bishop
somewhere to a six-song things like that
but I have this check yeah check on g5
and Queen takes Queen takes check hmm
maybe also if I take only five can you
go Bishop a sick so he can but it's a
great position right ok so I'll just
take this check
that that went really nicely he just
donated a pawn to the good course the
good course me being coming me coming
back to 2,400 always giving away even
more stuff here wait okay it's it's okay
from a technical point of view I can
trade this down to a quite basic rook
endgame and this is pretty simple I can
actually take here with check check then
check go here and winner yet another
pawn which is like three person resides
yeah he totally fell apart him with this
five move it was probably not very well
timed when we when we look at it and
keep missing tactics you know Bishop a3
is much stronger here I forgot about
this movie I thinking was briefly
thinking about Queen takes but this is a
strong ID i am here I'm getting the the
piece back with a great great
compensation compensation yeah I'm
getting the piece back and have a
fantastic position yet I already have
two pawns and yeah just just excellent
for me okay so this wasn't the best
possible reply it's still led to a nice
position but the other was just better
but this is the right way right takes
yeah okay I can take on the one but i
don't i don't mind him this tastes a
[ __ ] check and this young and winning up
yeah yeah black wins here it's a it's a
clearly dominant position the relatively
a best way to defend is this by the way
pink stakes takes rook chicks
and but this is something that white can
try to defend yeah it looks it looks bad
because of this totally ruin porn
structure but don't underestimate that
the rooks have opened file so there is
some activity here for white and I'm not
having an extra porn and better of
course but it's not yeah it doesn't win
itself still has to be has to be done
okay well thanks for watching